democracy and an ally of the West and
one is not Ally of the West what little
slip in there what's that got to do in
anything so allies of the West get to be
genocidal no why did you say Ally of the
West I don't catches pleas he like so
allies of the West it's okay for them
and he goes
no let's talk about life let's talk
about love if we talk about love then we
should talk about us and if we're
talking about us we need to talk about
growth they talk about you what they
should talk about both it's easier to
hate now harder to care we used to offer
help now we gossip and stare comment
like Swip share hate used to
be brothers and sisters and dear friends
today is a good day I like today yeah
good things are happening today yeah I'm
happy today aha nice it's rain today
yeah yeah it raining okay it's
raining hallelujah it's raining okay oh
Hallelujah yeah you're going to get ref
for that one I think that means a
praising God or something like that oh
now you're justifying it wow no so I was
going to do this reaction video about M
Hassan absolutely obliterating PS Morgan
I've never seen anyone get quau in the
moment and like the one thing I lik
about me was picking hold on a second
wait wait wait you said wait wait and I
love that he was just like stop no no
you're not just going to get away with
it people in debate they say things and
we just brush it over we this in the
bases and discussions we shouldn't let
people now hold on a second what do you
mean by that why did you say that word
let's because it was in person I think
it's a bit different because when he
does it when the person's on the monitor
there's a bit of a delay and he has a
bit an advantage I don't know if they do
it you know deliberately or whatever but
in person you can see the person's body
language you can cut them off and it's
instantaneous it's like there and then
and some of the points that he was
saying he was exposing the double
standards to another level phenomenal
eight highlights we have inshallah
brother and sisters we're going to watch
them one by one get your tea coffee
whatever you want ready inah cuz you're
going to love every moment it's going to
taste better than any dessert you're
having while you're watching this are
you ready and many people are not aware
of the fact that Israel occupied Lebanon
Southern Lebanon for 18 years from 1982
to 2000 when they withdrew although the
Lebanese argue that they're still an
occupation of a piece of Lebanese land
called the Sheba farms in Lebanon
they've killed 550 people PS on Monday
so the first thing if I'm not mistaken
is did you know that that Israel
occupied Lebanon for 18 years I didn't I
did you know that this is why hisbah
started no yes which shows you because
of the resist because of the occupation
people are resisting you can see that
for 18 years and that's why they pushed
them back this a saying nothing happens
in a vacuum and this is what try to say
of us in the Middle East they try to say
oh look at these barbarians randomly you
know um setting fire to themselves or
doing this and you know doing that no no
you don't randomly do that sort of Ni
not setting fire to them so in the
Middle East they'll say like oh look at
these people blowing themselves up look
at these people they're jealous of our
freedoms you got nothing better to do
yeah we're going to go after your
Western value Freedom your degeneracy
that's making your St go downhill
absolute nonsense in insane amount of
people in a single day one of the
highest single day death tolls in Modern
Warfare uh almost all of them civilians
according to the Lebanese Health
Ministry which is not hisbah by the way
you know they always say Hamas
controlled Health Ministry in Gaza when
we talk about Russia Ukraine you don't
do Subhan Allah yes 500 people killed
again in a bomb attack done by Israel
you know so we didn't know and this not
the pages we're not talking about the
pages the the attack that was happened
this terrorist attack that happened or
with those pages I mean if that happened
anywhere in the world there would be
absolute if if Putin did something like
that in Ukraine it would be over but
anyways and and the the crazy thing is
that when it comes to America they they
have a 911 they they are dedicating a
set of numbers that's been immortalized
forever when it came to the UK you got
77 when it comes to Israel you've got
October the 7th however what about over
here you know where's the
immortalization happening over here and
whenever death TOS happen when it comes
to Israel oh yeah Israel said this and
we're supposed to just accept it but it
was interesting the the distinction that
he made he said the these are actually
objective numbers before you try to
discredit them and further dehumanize
the people that have been murdered
exactly blame Russia as The Invader and
occupy you don't do that with Israel
that is the double standard on your part
I try be consistent P I'm morally
consistent I say Russia hold on let me
finish the sentence Russia illegally
invaded and occupied Israel and
illegally annexed the Crimea and Israel
is doing the same thing in the West Bank
Gaz of the Goan Heights as you know they
are completely different yeah Israel's
worse it's been going on much longer and
people living under much worse
conditions killed more kids there is no
similarity in these two situations
Israel's is worse it's not how many kids
have been killed in Ukraine versus Gaza
in in one year ever one year ever take
whatever point you want more kids have
been killed in Gaza in Ukraine every
Human Rights group agrees with that it's
not true booby traps are not allowed
it's not true uh it's I mean you cannot
make this this
year this year it's it's like he wanted
him to say yes and then the person
speaking in his air would have giving
him number but because he wasn't
specifying P Morgan was in a State of
Shock it's unbelievable and he's right
Hassan and even the Muslims we are here
morally consistent on this matter
because nowhere in our religion it tells
us to kill innocent men women children
we are morally consistent and Met's
right he's condemning both them to but
they don't the double standard have you
ever seen any discussion happening any
platform the one me Hass had with that
scumbag a whatever his name is yet
called was Russia's attack Justified
never you never dare to make a topic if
I made a rented out a a a and said we're
going to have a discussion was Russia's
actions um Justified shut down man shut
down you are not even allowed to talk
about it scums are not allowed if they
are genuinely indiscriminate in the way
that they you don't think going off in a
grocery store is indiscriminate no
actually I believe what I've you gave
the British example earlier P you okay
with someone blowing you up in in
sainsbury next to you blowing you up in
the I believe that what has been
reported right widely reported is that
3,000 terrorist militant head ball
members whatever you want to call them
were very precisely targeted are you
saying people by your criteria they go
off in grocer St hospital if it's legal
they go off in grocery stores and
hospitals no no you brought up the UK
earlier we're in London right now if I
go from here to the local sabur to pick
up some chocolate on the way out of the
studio and a terrorist is targeted next
to me they're blowing up in s and I get
lose my eyes you're saying that's okay
no but if if you have you're saying it's
okay if those people in that grocery
store are literally responsible for
firing rocket after rocket at you're
okay with them being blown up with me
I'm just clal out I actually looked at
what they did and I thought it was a
very precisely Target what about the 500
what about the 500 civilians killed on
Monday which you just don't want to talk
about the you see the the the fact that
he's trying to Gaslight us to believe
that a pager exploding in a grocery
store is precision attack this is
gaslighting on a whole another level
because you're seeing and he gave the
example that if we're in a grocery store
from wherever we're watching if someone
's device explodes how can you say it's
not affecting anyone else around him or
her and the fact that a girl 8 years old
she was killed as well yeah and even
some health official was in Lebanon who
work in hospitals uh this is this is
rhetoric that only these guys will come
with and Isis because it's the same
thing I mean you're justifying the uh
the the actions of individuals who would
go and carry these attacks out arguing L
say they tried to go and kill a soldier
and then a couple of people got killed
are you justifying that now no it's
interesting how for Israel the ends
justify the means however for everybody
else no no no no the means are you know
very important all RADS lead to the
occupation okay Israel would say all
roads lead to Iran who cares what Israel
says they've lied for the last year
they've lied what they say yeah do you
care what Russia says no this is what
I'm saying you're inconsistent the
occupier does I don't care it's not a
barbaric if you're a liberal democracy
for they're notal democracy and second
of all they are no they're not uh
they're ethnocracy but um even if they
were a liberal democracy you don't get
to invade other people's land that's not
an excuse PE you sounds like you're
justifying an illegal military
occupation here no I'm not you just did
you said they're a liberal democracy
sounds like you're justifying occation
you're extrapolating two things together
why I said it's occupation you said but
they're a liberal democracy sounds like
a justification me back to one thing you
take one side is that another hey hey if
you're liberal democracy yes you it's a
green light mate you can do what you
want exactly as long as you're a
democracy um that's beating and bombing
and Ming how many places has American
invaded oh for God's sake Al they're
liberal democracy I forgot man you
should remind me this Justified what
they're doing now how many Nation theyve
since World War II they've bombed 30
countries it's just the they democracy
how many has Iran look look they're not
liberal democracy don't no no yeah even
though I mean I don't support the regime
that I'll be honest with you but the
point is this
hypocrisy just like you do in Ukraine
yes yeah so I'm consistent I take the
side of the Ukrainian people under
occupation and the Palestinian people
under occupation I'm consistent people
no you're not they they're totally
different situations that's you have to
say that because you're not consistent
and you have to say what you say no but
I literally described it two people's
under foreign occupation two people's
having their hospitals bombed two
people's having their kids killed two
people facing governments that say
genocidal stuff yeah I'm consistent one
is a democracy and an ally of the West
and one is not Ally of the West what
little slip in there what's that got to
do in anything so allies of the West get
to be genocidal no why did you say Ally
of the West I don't believe I don't
believe what they're doing in so if
Russia was an ally of the West they
could kill people in Ukraine and there
were no nuclear weapons back then p as
yeah so this was interesting it's you
know you know you know when know when he
catches pleas he's like so allies of the
West it's okay for them and he goes no
it's like when you catch a child with
his hand in a cookie jar are you taking
that Cookie Out the Cookie job no
no this was a knockout bro well it's
it's as if bro if m h had the same
debate and they had one about Israel and
Gaza and then they had another one about
Russia and Ukraine and if you watch them
simultaneously it's it's you'll be
shocked because when the the Ally ship
changes his whole topic how he defends
Israel he doesn't do the same it's it's
cut and dry literally do you support
Russia no do you defend the you know
what I mean it's cut and dry but when it
comes to Israel and Palestine it's
complicated it's it's different but they
only just they're defending themselves
it shows you bro basically they are full
outright this it's it's like living in
Nazi Germany they have dehumanized the
Muslims that when these attacks when
were happening in Europe when Russia was
attacking Ukraine journalists were
coming and saying these is these are
things that you see happening in the
Middle East this shouldn't be happening
to blueeyed blond you're thinking you're
thinking where this where is this retor
coming from because they don't see the
Muslims and the brown people as human
beings so they see you less it's like
Eugenics this what H believed in you
know the the you know the the the um the
race that is higher like the Aryan you
know this is what they're doing they are
basically saying we are better you guys
you getting killed is okay you see this
rhetoric and lastly the last one in okay
but you think Putin would ever use him
do you not think he would no why would
he he's not an Islamic fundamentalist
who wants to blow himself up oh that's a
very racist thing to say it's not you're
saying only Muslims want to use nuclear
I said why would Putin not want to use
Muslim I said Islamic fundamentalist why
is it Islamic fundamentalist what's
because Islamic fundamentalists kill
themselves get what they want but they
haven't used nukes the only people have
used nukes in history are the United
you're missing Point deliberately and
you're because you're playing the race
card stupidly you know the United States
of America used the nuclear weapon peers
right they're not Islamic
fundamentalists you're missing my point
the point is Islamic fundamentalists
will kill themselves in the process of
destroying others this one is
interesting this one's interesting
America using nuclear weapons only ones
by the way only ones to drop nuclear
weapons yes Hiroshima and Nagasaki
killed hundreds of thousand people and
the effects are there to stay which kids
been born you know disabled and many
okay so let's use an argument Islamic
fundamental terrorists go and kill their
self and others which is by by the way
nothing to do with Islam America they
don't kill theel they kill others so so
and affecting the generations and
generations come so the logic is if you
kill yourself and others you are worse
than somebody killing others what the
hell are you talking about man killing
others is wrong period is objectively
wrong to kill other people so what are
you on about about individual going and
killing himself which is against Islam
and any other religion suicide and then
killing other innocent people but you're
justifying and equating that or there's
equation of an a a person going and
dropping a bomb from the sky hundreds of
thousands of people are being blown up
and I believe America used that as just
like you know what just as like a test
because back then the Japanese have
given up they surrendered yeah and
that's that's absolutely right because
if you there's a chapter on this in
people's history of America by Howard
Zen in which he talks about their
military experts and talks about how the
leader of America then had received
intelligence that they yeah that that
they were pretty much ready
there were few conditions being
negotiated there but there was no to
drop the at bombs however they wanted to
do it as a deterrent ironically to
Russia yes I mean guys hope you enjoyed
that I loved every second of it I mean I
need to you know what I we need to thank
Pier cuz I genuinely start to believe
either he's psychologically lost it
because his show has aided the Palestine
cause immensely and I'm not saying he
does it intentionally I mean I don't
even know actually to this I'm think
this guy intentionally thinking you know
what I can't speak out against it let me
just bring these guys and let them just
destroy me cuz they have I mean is this
a way I mean Pi it's very strategic and
very clever you know what it is uh I
think the thing with p is he just wants
views and this topic he's noticed with a
few videos it gets views and sometimes
because obviously people are saying they
have brain cells and they can see that
Palestinians are the ones being harmed
and when he does a pro-israeli video he
then has to go on the other side and but
the thing is when he goes to the other
Pro Palestinian side the pro Palestinian
side
fires shots like M Hassan has that the
other side simply cannot he P actually
has to help the other side but by not
asking them challenging questions that
again M Hassan was saying I was watching
you asking the questions you weren't
challenging them at all however when it
comes with the prop Palestinians the
same old rhetoric do you condemn October
7th do you condemn Hamas do you condemn
this the same old and even despite that
mallah some of the voices that have come
to the four because you know I don't
think he does it deler you know what it
is is Allah's help is with the righteous
exactly alhamd they have been exposed
with their own tongues and like they
said before brother sisters I will use
it again and hopefully I'll go make it
good I'll say it in the right right way
nothing justifies October the 7th but
everything that happens after October
7th justifies it I think that makes
sense the biggest hypocrisy
alhamdulillah may Allah give Victory to
those who are being oppressed and their
time is coming whether they are allies
of the west or all whether they are
democracy or not alhamdulillah brother
and sisters